often oftentimes girls like will say
they don't have a type but if I look at
their exes they kind of look the same
right yeah no I'll get that but then I
think sometimes you can have they might
have a one-off but like usually it'll be
like this guy like similar somewhere one
off similar similar blokes make it past
the certain stage you know I get that
it's just my I don't know I think I'm
quite varied with that I don't think you
could look at my day in history and see
a pattern if I'm honest you know you
don't think that women like the guys
that other women want yes
you don't think we kind of go for the
same guy like if we walk into if we have
10 guys walk into a room we'll find the
same ones attractive if Eddie walks into
a room right now if Eddie walks into a
room right now do you think that most of
the women in the room will be looking at
Eddie
as just as opposed to a man that doesn't
look like Eddie well it depends on the
other man it's like I'm like yeah
you hear that you hear that hypergamy no
I'm just saying like most of the time
women want uh the guy that other women
want because women essentially like
competition
they the thing is I think it's it's not
even a conscious thing sometimes it is
but I think sometimes it's a
subconscious thing I think if if we were
to bring like three other women into
this room right now right
um they would be sizing the ladies up in
this room right they would be like oh
what is her hair like what's she got
makeup on do you know what I mean like
what's she wearing like women like
competition like that's how they are and
the thing is they're in that competition
because of men
because they're looking generally
looking for the same guy yeah yeah I
think roll automatic calls it
competition anxiety right so in that
situation yeah women will come into the
room and it's like
it's it's it's a game of like who's
gonna be the Lioness in the room type
thing right but then for the guy
if that same guy walked in with let's
say two attractive women then all the
women start to get curious as to why why
is he with those women yeah and why do
they like attractive weird what makes
them so attractive and that's when they
start calculating that I'm trying to
understand what this guy's about so
yeah it's very interesting how I
wouldn't behave in those environments do
you think that I'm curious if you see a
guy
um his ex-girlfriend like you're
interested in a guy and you see his
ex-girlfriend was morbidly
and a single mother with three kids from
three different dads does that
does that change your opinion on him are
you equally interested in that changes
my opinion on him because it's about
choices it's about yeah like who what
sort of level have you been operating at
not in a rude way but who have you
chosen to be with that's not necessarily
just based on aspects but if a man is
willing to go with a woman who's got
several fathers to to her children to me
you're not making the choices that are
what what if he met to me like he might
not have any other option right she
would pick then do you need to look at
your choices and how you ended up with
that man or is it that some some guys
will end up with females like it's
easier for them because they like
control or power so if you look at a lot
of relationships that are like
unfortunately like abusive in whatever
way whether that's mentally or
physically yeah so control element where
they'll go with women who are more
vulnerable who don't have that
confidence who are insecure because it's
easier for them to and bigger girls men
like them they were bigger girls get
what they want out of those women I
think a lot of girls in toxic
relationships are toxic themselves 100
views back 100 like I don't I don't find
that it's often like the vulnerable ones
like I I just find that like it's the
equally toxic ones I think narcissists
and there's a lot of studies on this the
narcissists attract
um attract input diet and impact yeah so
that's where that comes from if you've
got someone that then there's numerous
studies about this you can look online
about this there's numerous [ __ ] about
this online
so you see when it comes to like the
whole dating thing
um it's so crazy to me like actually
looking at the whole data map datar and
the way in which human beings interact
um is it easier to portray yourself what
we already know is it easy to portray
yourself as somebody else and when it's
time
to meet that person if you've guys been
doing that because I haven't have you
met somebody from a dating app
and then been like this person is
nothing like what they say so not not
physically I'm talking about the
quote-unquote vibe Vibe I just think
social media in general is all about
perception yeah that perception is king
So people do things to paint a certain
perception of themselves but that may
not necessarily be a reality of the
situation I think when I was when I was
studying a decision in consumer science
they call those a public sphere and a
privacy so now in this digital world
people have multiple
um realities that they can kind of
create for themselves right so there's
there's the digital reality it's like an
avatar it's like an avatar exactly that
so there's a digital reality is that
there's the real world reality right the
digital reality is where you you get the
people in like games like second life
where they've just created this this
fantasy of who they are and what they're
aspiring to be and to some degree they
think that's them and then you meet them
in the real world and it's just it's
nothing like it so the energy in the
vibe is all different
have you ever met a girl that seems
really sweet and then you look at her
Instagram and it's just
well I didn't met her in person yeah
better in person you're like oh she
seems so innocent perception changes
like that literally like that and then
you see like her Instagram and it's
great because that's happened to me a
couple of times on the show where a girl
come in I'm like oh she's such a sweet
and then you look at it and then I have
her Instagram like oh my God like what
matters seriously which makes you like
ask a question why if you are this
innocent cool chill person
in person why do you feel the need to
show that because people are insecure on
the internet and social media makes
people go into this world where they're
competing with each other and majority
of these people are not even happy a lot
of the people that post certain things
they might not even be in joint they're
just going with the crowd because people
don't want to think outside of the
boxing because they feel like they might
be lonely or they're not with the crowd
The In Crowd or this that the other
they're just following suit that of
things that other people are doing but I
think with women women have this like
from from a biological standpoint this
like kind of group mentality so when
they see other women doing certain
things and getting success off it they
feel like you know you need to emulate
that to be in this group and not hence
the BBL culture hence the BBL culture
makeup blowing up your lips etc etc so
you don't want to be ostracized from any
group and if you see a certain group of
women getting success doing certain
things and you think okay that's what I
need to do to get the man that I want
it's a similar it's the same thing with
what men men will say we want natural
women who have natural beauty but then
women will say but you the girl with the
fake bum in the big box yes that was a
[ __ ] around Wi-Fi and and again we
say this on a regular basis there's
certain women that we there's a caliber
woman that would [ __ ] a caliber woman
that would have we tell you the caliber
women that we'd wife but you see what we
go for in terms of just quick
interactions and you seem to assume that
that is what men want when they're right
the thing is right on on the flip side
of that is because the society in which
we live in is a get
is a half culture we are living in the
hookup culture we are living in the
hookup generation right and so the
reason why women are getting confused by
that is because because everybody's
hooking up with each other
um and they're seeing the the people
that are getting the attention for the
hookups women are thinking
I need to do that right but generally
human beings are not looking for
anything long-term women I think women
looking through beer goggles because
it's like beer cookies you because to me
what you should be paying attention to
is who the women that are married and
it's not the ones with bbls and blowing
up lips if you look at the women that
are married they're
they're not even like tens they're like
just like I see it this is where I
disagree this is what's confusing to
women and I I understand like from my
point of view that a lot of times the
girls that are married are just bad
wives but I've had girls on the show
that are married and I look at their
Instagram and they're thoughting it up
on Instagram and it's like men put up
with a lot of [ __ ] and it's because men
are feminized though no I said no I
agree I agree but I'm saying like
there's a lot of bad like one out of
four marriages are sexless those girls
still get a ring they're syphilis I hear
that but then these women don't look
like the bbo like they think the Kim
Kardashians
they're not those girls like those are
the girls that men just [ __ ] get rid
of so cool those women exist and they're
doing the madness on Instagram but
they're not the ones who have the the
Cosmetic work done yeah as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible